hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live allein in den letzten drei Tagen in
mindestens drei Städten hat das
ukrainische Militär nach eigenen Angaben
russische Truppen und Technik getroffen
hunderte russische Soldaten sollen dabei
getötet worden sein behauptet die
Ukraine aber einen der Angriffe die das
bestätigt selbst das russische
Verteidigungsministerium und spricht
selbst von 63 Toten nur 63 Toten und
trotzdem ist dieses Eingeständnis
interessant denn Moskau äußert sich nur
sehr selten zu eigenen Verlusten
passiert ist das ganze in der
Silvesternacht nach einem ukrainischen
Raketenangriff die Soldaten wurden in
der Stadt markiska auf russisch
besetzten Gebiet im Osten der Ukraine
getötet
und heute unsere Frage im Livestream wie
massiv sind denn diese russischen
Verluste der letzten Tage wirklich wie
lange kann Putin noch Krieg führen und
bleibt ihm am Ende vielleicht nur ein
Waffenstillstand darüber wollen wir
sprechen und diskutieren ihr könnt wie
immer gerne mit kommentieren direkt im
Stream oder auch Fragen stellen und
natürlich auch per Mail und zuerst
wollen wir sprechen mit dem
militär-experten Oberst ade Wolfgang
Richter schönen guten Abend Herr Richter
schönen guten Abend
am Anfang der Sendung auch die Bilder
der Zerstörung gesehen haben gehört es
gibt wieder wie immer sehr
unterschiedliche Angaben zu den
Verlusten ihre Einschätzung jetzt am
Anfang wie hoch sind denn die Verluste
wirklich wenn man da so zwei
unterschiedliche Zahlen hört
ja zunächst einmal muss man sagen dass
beide Seiten natürlich im Krieg auch
Propaganda betreiben das heißt der
eigenen Verluste werden ungern bekannt
gegeben wenn dann werden sie
heruntergerechnet und die anderen
Verluste eben entsprechend erhöht
trotzdem glaube ich ist es hier
eindeutig das sieht man auch an den
Reaktionen aus der russischen
Bloggerszene das doch die Verluste in
markiska erheblich gewesen sein müssen
sie mögen vielleicht nicht bei 400
liegen man muss dann auch immer
unterscheiden zwischen kriegsverlusten
die aber nicht alle gefallene bedeuten
sondern man muss dann etwa 25 bis 30 %
davon als gefallener rechnen die anderen
sind dann verwundet und wir haben
natürlich zusätzlich auch über Verluste
gehört im Raum
und da sind dann schon erhebliche
Verluste für die russische Armee die in
die Hunderte gehen allerdings geben auch
die Ukraine nicht bekannt welche eigenen
Verluste sie nun erlitten haben
insgesamt kann sich das schon summieren
so mal wieder davon ausgehen müssen so
zumindest die Geheimdienstberichte dass
wir auf beiden Seiten mittlerweile etwa
100.000
kriegsausfälle haben also noch einmal
nicht alles gefallen aber doch gut 25 30
% davon gefallen und das sind schon
herbe Verluste auch beiden Seiten
wir haben allerdings in Russland eine
Bewegung gesehen die zu Erhöhung der
Streitkräfte führen soll eben um diese
Verluste auszugleichen erstens schon
seit einigen Monaten die
teilmobilisierung von rund 300.000
Soldaten
und zweitens was gilt ab jetzt ab Januar
eine Erhöhung der russischen
Streitkräfte von rund einer Million auf
1,5 Millionen Mann also plus 137.000 ist
die genaue Zahl und das heißt wenn diese
Personalzahlen an die Front gelangen
dann glaube ich so wie man das jetzt
einschätzen kann dass beide Seiten jetzt
zu Anfang 2023 erstens gewählt sind
politisch und auch entsprechend
motiviert sind diesen Krieg vorzuführen
das Geld in Russland allerdings nur für
die Führung wie die Moral der Truppe
aussieht können wir nur
schätzen das ist natürlich schwieriger
für die russische Moderator der
russischen Truppen auf einen Bruder
Erfolg zu schießen und sich dann die
Frage zu stellen was machen wir hier
eigentlich als für die Ukraine deren
Kampfmoral der nun nachgewiesen sehr
hoch ist und die auch wissen wofür sie
kämpfen nämlich für die Souveränität und
Unabhängigkeit des Landes die zweite
Frage die man hier stellen muss ist wie
viele Ressourcen auch materiell in
materieller Hinsicht stehen und
eigentlich zur Verfügung
und wie viel Personal könnten beide
Seiten insgesamt noch mobilisieren und
all diese Fragen auf alle Antworten auf
diese Fragen deuten darauf hin dass wir
auf ein schnelles Kriegsende leider
jetzt nicht warten können oder dass es
nicht absehbar ist zumindest sondern das
offenbar beide Seiten gewählt sind und
möglicherweise auch in der Lage sind
diesen Krieg doch noch eine ganze Weile
fortsetzen wir gehen auch gleich noch
mehr ins Detail sprechen gleich mit
ihnen weiter Fragen aber kurz bei
unserem Reporter in der Ukraine bei Tim
Krüger nach denn dort ist er in den
letzten drei Tagen also der Ukraine auf
jeden Fall ein sehr präziser Schlag
gelungen mit auf jeden Fall auch einigen
russischen Verlusten wie konnte die
Ukraine so erfolgreich sein Team dass
sie da so gezielt auch wirklich an
gleich drei Orten angreifen konnte
also die ukrainische Militärführung gibt
dazu natürlich nichts offizielles Preis
sie hält sich in diesen Dingen sehr
bedeckt ganz einfach sie will natürlich
nicht ihre Strategie ihre Taktik ihre
Möglichkeiten bekannt geben aber es gibt
durchaus einige Informationen wie das
möglich gewesen sein konnte in diesem
Fall sind es vor allem militärische
kremlarer
militärblogger die dort ganz offenbar
über Informationen verfügen und eine
Theorie ist eben dass die vielfache
Benutzung von Handys innerhalb dieser
sich dort versammelten Truppe in der
Silvesternacht offenbar zu einem Signal
geführt hat was die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte aufnehmen konnten dass sie
Orten konnten und so dann eben diesen
Ort an dem sich die russischen Truppen
versammelt haben angreifen konnten wenn
dem so wäre wäre das natürlich
militärisch ein ziemlich fataler Fehler
und wir hören jetzt auch schon dass sich
die Kritik an der russischen
Kriegsführung für Russland also dass
diese Kritik langsam lauter wird und sie
könnte eben noch mal lauter werden wir
haben es gerade gehört der ukrainische
generalstaat hat heute noch mal einen
weiteren Angriff bekannt gegeben ein
Angriff in einem Ort in der Region rason
der dich auch am Neujahrstag ereignet
haben soll dort sind allein von 500
Toten und Verletzten die Rede das ist
eine sehr hohe Zahl die wir natürlich
überhaupt nicht verifizieren können aber
wenn sich diese Zahl auch nur annähernd
bestätigt dann wäre das wirklich ein
haber ein sehr verlustreicher neuer Tag
für die russischen Streitkräfte gewesen
und man kann sich leicht vorstellen dass
solche Angriffe auf die russischen
Truppen in den besetzten Gebieten der
Ukraine gerade was die Moral angeht
fatal sind
und das gab aber auch natürlich wieder
auch in den letzten Tagen also russische
Angriffe auch erfolgreiche Angriffe wir
haben auch Bilder können kurz drauf
schauen ein russischer Raketenangriff
hat eben eine Stadt in der Region dann
jetzt getroffen hier soll zu sehen sein
die eishockey-arena der größten Schule
für Eishockey und Eiskunstlauf in der
Ukraine also da auch wieder viel
Zerstörung die wir sehen es ist
natürlich schwer dann die Verluste auf
ukrainischer Seite die dann auch nicht
preisgegeben werden zu beziffern aber
was weißt Du noch über diesen Angriff
oder die erfolgreichen Angriffe
Russlands in den letzten Tagen Tim
also was die Opferzahlen angeht ist die
Zahl die sich seit gestern Morgen oder
die wir seit gestern Morgen hören
beläuft sich auf drei Personen das ist
auch eine Teil die wir natürlich
überhaupt nicht verifizieren können und
dies natürlich klingt viel geringer als
das was wir auf russischer Seite hören
aber
wir wissen beispielsweise überhaupt
nicht was beispielsweise an der Front
passiert wie viel ukrainische Soldaten
dort in den letzten 24 Stunden gefallen
sind das ist schwer zu sagen aber was
sich offenbar in der letzten Nacht etwas
beruhigt hat waren zumindest diese
Drohnenangriffe es gab in den ersten
beiden Tagen nach Neujahr ähm eine
durchaus massive Welle mit Dutzenden von
Angriffen viele dieser Drohnen sind zwar
abgefangen worden aber dann sind eben
diese
Teile heruntergestürzt und haben
durchaus Schaden angerichtet und wenn
man dem ukrainischen Präsident selenski
glauben kann dann wird sich wenn sich
dieser Angriffe auch wiederholen
jetzt offenbart die ukrainische
Regierung Informationen dass es zu
weiteren Wellen kommen wird und wenn
sich diese Informationen bestätigen dann
werden auch die nächsten Tage und Wochen
hier in der Ukraine unruhig werden
vielen Dank für die Einschätzung live
aus der Ukraine Tim Krüger
und wir haben es am Anfang der Sendung
habe ich schon angesprochen also 63
Opfer auf russischer Seite das hat
Russland selbst Moskau selbst zugegeben
aber das fällt selbst einigen Menschen
in Russland schwer zu glauben es gibt
immer mehr Kritik zuletzt von russischen
kriegsreportern und eben auch online und
wir schauen in einen Bericht von Anton
kuscheln dazu
es sind nur noch Trümmer übrig von der
russischen Militär Unterkunft in der
Region jetzt bei dem Angriff starben 63
Soldaten sagt Moskau Kiew spricht von
400 Toten der Angriff hat den Russland
Kritik ausgelöst die Militärführung habe
die Soldaten auf engstem Raum und in der
Nähe von Waffen und Munition
einquartiert
Igor gilkin ehemaliger Befehlshaber pro
russischer Truppen in der Ukraine findet
deutlich geworden auf telegram das ist
nicht der einzige extrem dichte Einsatz
von Personal und Material an einem Ort
in Schussweite der amerikanischen Thomas
Raketen und ja dieses nicht der erste
derartige Vorfall im vergangenen Jahr
gab es davon viele aber unsere Generäle
sind im Prinzip nicht lernfähig ihre
Kritik soll sich heute in Grenzen
gehalten haben Angehörige und Freunde
trauern im russischen Samara um die
getöteten Soldaten
gehört also es gibt auch inzwischen
immer mehr kritische Stimmen Herr
Richter Obers ade Wolfgang Richter sonst
noch mal zugeschaltet wie sehr schadet
denn so etwas der russischen
Kriegsführung wenn da jetzt Kritik laut
wird tatsächlich
also wir hören ja schon seit einiger
Zeit interne Kritik an der russischen
Kriegsführung bisher hat sie hat sich
die Kritik in erster Linie auf die
militärische Führung konzentriert es ist
frappieren dass die politische Führung
noch nicht in der Kritik stehen oder was
man sich nicht traut was zu tun aber
eines in einem hat Georgien der ja auch
noch kein unbeschriebenes Blatt ist
erinnere sich an das Jahr 2014 in einem
hatte aber recht wenn man ihn Reichweite
vom Heimat Raketen er Rekruten eine also
eine doch sehr starke Gruppe von etwa
einem Bataillon auf einem Gebäude oder
in einem Gebäude komplett konzentriert
und ist das ein schwerer Fehler in der
Kriegsführung gerade unter der Bedrohung
von Langstrecken Raketen muss man
auflockern oder man muss über einen
entsprechenden Schutz verfügen deswegen
wird ja auch in der russischen
blockerszene aber auch mittlerweile bei
Politikern die Kritik an der
militärischen Führung geäußert und habe
nicht ausreich über den Schutz getan man
müsste mehr Erstellungen bauen die auch
betoniert sind also gehärtet sind etc
und das müsste man mit dringend an die
Front bringen in einem anderen Punkt hat
Gerken auch recht es ist nicht das erste
Mal dass das passiert und ich frage mich
warum man hier nicht lernfähig ist dass
man immer noch konzentriert statt
aufzulockern und dass man immer noch
zulässt dass man über Handy sozusagen
die eigenen Stellungen verrät denn es
ist natürlich heute mit der modernen
Elektronik mit elektronischen Aufklärung
erleichtes Handy Daten und damit auch
die
Ortung der festzustellen und dann
unmittelbar mit Artillerie und
Langstrecken zu reagieren darin sind die
Ukraine übrigens Meister und das müssten
die Russen eigentlich mittlerweile
erkannt haben dass das jetzt am neuer
Tag noch mal passiert ist schon
erstaunlich ich glaube insgesamt geht es
aber darum dass man die Moral der
eigenen Truppe fördern will dass man die
Moral des Gegners noch mal beschädigen
will und dass man das am Donnerstag tut
hat natürlich auch symbolischen
Charakter es läutet ein neues Jahr ein
wo man signalisieren will wir sind
bereit und wir sind in der Lage euch
weiter erhebliche Verluste beizubringen
was die Ukraine natürlich nicht sagen
ist welche eigenen verlässte sie
inzwischen erlitten haben dann auch die
Russen führen natürlich den Krieg weiter
sie machen praktische Vorstöße in
bonn-bass und es scheint so kleineren in
der taktischen vorstoßen auf beiden
Seiten gekommen zu sein die aber nicht
mehr als zwei drei Kilometer tiefer
haben also das ist keine strategische
Veränderung aber es zeigt doch den
Willen diesen Krieg vorzusetzen und wir
müssen davon ausgehen wir haben es
vorhin erwähnt dass leider ein kurzes
Ende dieses Krieges nicht in Sicht ist
und wir haben Fragen dazu bei uns im
Stream Daniel silver bei Youtube
schreibt wäre jetzt nicht die Zeit
Panzer zu schicken damit die Ukraine
diesen damit die Ukraine diesen Krieg
beenden kann
ich antworte immer sofort auf die Fragen
wenn ich das richtig sehe
ich glaube die Annahme dass durch einen
Durchführung von Kampfpanzern der Krieg
beendet werden kann nicht ganz
realistisch ist die Ukraine hat bereits
Kampfbahn zu erhalten ich erinnere daran
dass sie nach den Russen die
panzerstärkste Armee in Europa immer
noch ist sie war es ganz sicher am 24
Februar des letzten Jahres als der Krieg
begann sie haben viermal so viel Kampf
an seinem aktiven Dienst und ungefähr
1000 in den Kurs stehen gehabt davon
sind sicherlich auch viele reaktiviert
worden aber es gab ja auch
Panzerlieferungen von osteuropäischen
Staaten von gleichen Typen die auch die
ukrainische Armee fahren
insofern sind die Verluste zu einem
großen Teil auch ausgeglichen worden ich
glaube was im Moment das wichtigste ist
für die Ukraine ist die Luftabwehr denn
diese strategischen lufteingriffe mit
Drohnen Marshmallow Frauen und Raketen
beschädigen natürlich die
vor allem die Energie- und
Elektrizitätsversorgung der Ukraine und
die ist ungeheuer wichtig nicht nur
deswegen weil die Lichter ausgehen oder
es kalt werden wird in den Städten
sondern vor allem weil die
Rüstungsproduktion der Ukraine die ja
sehr stark ist darunter leiden leitet
dass sie keine Energie mehr hat und auch
die Logistik die wir von West nach Ost
über einen langen gezeigt lange Strecke
gehen muss wird unterbrochen da die
ukrainische Eisenbahn mit Wasser
elektrifiziert fährt und das sind alles
Militärische Gesichtspunkte die auch
berücksichtigt werden müssen weil in
dieser Frage das heißt auf der anderen
Seite sehen wir eine sehen wir russische
Ressourcen die noch lange nicht
ausgeschöpft sind wir haben in den
Depots tausende von Kampf waren stehen
die sind nicht modern die sind nicht die
allermeisten aber sie sind in Masse
verfügbar wenn sie dann vernünftig
wieder entstand gesetzt werden was ich
zumindest von einem Teil annehme dann
werden habt ihr Russen sehr viele
Kampfpanzer ins Gefecht führen das heißt
das wird nicht der sichere Weg sein um
den Krieg rasch zu beenden und die
wiederoberung wird nicht so einfach sein
wie man sich das vorstellt man muss ja
immer beide Seiten sehen und man muss
auch sehen wie unterschiedlich die
Ressourcen gestaltet sind in Russland
sind sie vor allen Dingen national noch
vorhanden eben in den Depots während die
Ukraine je mehr Waffen sie von dem
westlichen Staaten erhält je mehr wird
sie auch auf die Logistik angewiesen
sein denn das ganze muss versorgt werden
das braucht Ersatzteile ist man muss
Munition liefern und wir haben
mittlerweile festgestellt welche
Engpässe wir im Westen haben mit der
Kriegsproduktion und mit der
Munitionsversorgung insbesondere das
heißt die Umstellung auf
kriegs-produktion ist ja noch lange
nicht erledigt und ich wage im Moment
sogar zu zweifeln ob das in kurzer Zeit
erfolgen wird und das sind ja tiefer
Einschnitte in die Privatwirtschaft der
Rüstungsindustrie wenn man jetzt einfach
sagt verdoppelt verdreifacht mal die
Munitionsmenge die ihr liefern oder
produzieren könnt dann müssen die
Staaten Garantien geben dass auf Jahre
hinaus auch abzunehmen so einfach wird
dass die Industrie alleine natürlich
nicht tun ja das sind alles in die Frage
die konkrete Nachfrage an sie er liefert
denn der Westen genug Waffen und
Munition um der Ukraine dann überhaupt
den Sieg zu ermöglichen
ja dann ist nur die Frage was man unter
sich versteht also wenn man
unterscheidet sich ja auch in der
politischen Wortwahl da sehr deutlich es
ist ein Unterschied ob man sagt die
Ukraine darf nicht verlieren sie muss
Unabhängigkeit behalten oder wir wollen
einen Sieg Erreichen der dann auch die
Krim einschließt das heißt also ein eine
Rückeroberung sozusagen dessen was seit
2014 bis 2022 verloren wurde und was
auch dann verliert oder jedenfalls
militärisch nicht mehr fragen kann und
politisch hat man sich im Minsk Abkommen
ja eher um den Don was gekümmert und
weniger um die Krim das heißt das wäre
dann eine neue Dimension des Krieges
oder ob es etwa darum geht was auch
schon geäußert worden ist die russische
Armee zum Ruin zu bringen also wir
müssen da sehr gut unterscheiden was das
eigentlich bedeutet dieses Wort sieht
und ich glaube man darf dann aber auch
nicht übersehen dass es
selbstverständlich auch die Gefahr der
Erweiterung oder der Eskalation des
Krieges gibt darauf hingewiesen dass die
ressourcenlage noch lange nicht
erschöpft ist leider es ist noch nicht
gelungen Russland weltweit zu isolieren
was Sanktionen betrifft das sind
Sanktionen des Westens ein großer Teil
des globalen Südens macht wirklich mit
selbst ein nato-staat in die Türkei
machte nicht mit das heißt auch an
dieser Stelle ist das Sanktionsregime
löchrek insofern sollten wir nicht zu
euphorisch sein es liegen natürlich
Risiken auf beiden Seiten das muss man
deutlich sagen auch die Russen werden
nicht ohne weiteres so viel mobilisieren
können ohne dass es in den Familien die
immer mehr hineingezogen werden in
diesen Krieg so Unruhe kommt und wenn
diese Unruhe die politischen Eliten
erreicht dann kann es auch für gut in
eng werden also diese riesigen bestehen
auf beiden Seiten wir müssen selber
analytisch unterscheiden und er sollten
nicht zu leichtfertig und schnell vom
sie sprechen nur wenn man wieder 30 40
ich möchte gerne auch die Kommentare aus
unserer Community mal vorlesen Frank
lange schreibt bei Facebook
Waffenstillstand während der erste
Schritt Madara bei Youtube schreibt ich
hoffe dass alle Menschen in Deutschland
verstehen dass die Ukraine verdammt noch
mal das Recht haben ihre Land zu
verteidigen und das für immer und ewig
und noch ein letzter und daran
anschließend dann auch eine Frage von
Askan Grunewald per Mail kam folgender
Kommentar wie kommen einige Experten
darauf dass die Ukraine an einem
Waffenstillstand interessiert ist das
käme einem Sieg Russland gleich
schließlich ist deren primär Ziel seit
2014 die Einverleibung der Regionen
Johanns und jetzt und der Grimm wie ist
da ihre Einschätzung also wie kommen
einige Experten darauf dass die Ukraine
an einem Waffenstillstand überhaupt
interessiert sein könnte
also die ukrainische Regierung hatte
zumindest Ende März durchaus das
Interesse gezeigt es gab dort
Verhandlungen zwischen der ukrainischen
und der russischen einer ukrainischen
und russischen Delegation und Präsident
selenski selbst hat das
verhandlungsvorläufige
Verhandlungsergebnis verkündet es
lautete
erstens die Ukraine tritt nicht der nah
dabei
zweitens die Frage der das politischen
Staates der Krim wird um 15 Jahre
verschoben
um dann den Staat was letztendlich
festlegen das bedeutet ja ein Klartext
eine Anerkennung der defacto Kontrolle
nicht der Junge also nicht rechtlich
aber de facto Kontrolle der Creme sowie
das ja auch in den letzten acht Jahren
vor Kriegsbeginn der Fall war durch die
Russen drittens die Verhandlung eines
Sonderstatus für den dornbas zwischen
den beiden Präsidenten und das erinnert
mich ein bisschen anders minzgrabkommen
zwei man könnte das dann also mit
reinnehmen dazu kamen Sicherheit
garantieren für die Ukraine aber eben
außerhalb der NATO und weitere
humanitäre Maßnahmen Gefangenen
Austausch etc also all diese Dinge waren
schon einmal weit gereift und sind dann
aber zerschlagen worden
aus verschiedenen Gründen die Frage ist
nur gab es danach in realistischeren
Ansatz für ein Waffenstillstand und wenn
man über Waffenstillstand redet dann
muss man auch immer die Frage stellen
unter welchen Bedingungen eigentlich
selbstverständlich hat die Ukraine ein
verteidigungsrecht und
selbstverständlich ist es klar dass man
auf westlicher Seite her unterstützt das
ist eine freie souveräne und unabhängige
Ukraine geben wird auf der anderen Seite
stehen und dann aber auch die Risiken
und die weiteren Verluste wir haben
gerade eben Verluste gesprochen eines
Krieges und die Frage wird man immer
irgendwann mal stellen müssen wie weit
treibt man das und wo sind dann
Kompromisslinien kann man zurückkehren
einen vernünftigen Kompromisslinien von
Ende März das heißt aber auch die beide
Seiten in dem Fall also auch sogar die
Ukraine müssten von maximalpositionen
wieder
Eroberungen der Creme Rückeroberung der
Creme und dann absehen während die
Russen selbstverständlich auf imperiale
Ambitionen wie die Einverleibung von
vier neuen
oblasten ebenfalls verzichten müssen
also die Frage der Diplomatie lautet ja
in einer scheinbar ausweglosen Lage wie
jetzt wo die Position überhaupt nicht
übereinstimmen kann man irgendwo ein Tor
öffnen was für mehr vertrauen dann führt
und vielleicht dadurch andere Kurve
aufgeht beispielsweise die Frage der
NATO Mitgliedschaft miteinander noch
einmal diskutiert wahrscheinlich das ist
meine begriffliche Nachricht wird so
eine Einsicht doch erst kommen wenn die
Opferzahl noch weiter ansteigen das ist
jetzt kein erfreuliche Botschaft zu
Beginn des Jahres aber wenn die
leidensfähig der Leidensdruck so weit
Ste dass man sich bewegen muss und man
kann natürlich hoffen dass das der Fall
ist aber voraussehen kann sie das jetzt
nicht und wer heute meint er könnte
schon gewisse Daten angeben wann der
Krieg zu einem Ende kommt und unter
welchen Bedingungen ich glaube das ist
der Blick in die Kristallkugel und das
sind Spekulation an den ich mich dann
auch nicht beteiligen möchte
es gibt viele Fragen bei uns im Stream
natürlich klar dieser Krieg hat so viele
Facetten und da gibt's natürlich auch
viele hier Ideen und Fragen wie könnte
er wann überhaupt zu Ende gehen ich
möchte einige davon jetzt hier noch
aufgreifen und zwar schreibt Couch los
Studio bei Youtube Herr Richter haben
die hat die Ukraine denn genug Truppen
für einen abnutzungskrieg könnten die
Russen allein mit Mann stärker den Krieg
noch drehen
rein zahlenmäßig könnte man das
sicherlich so sehen ich meine die
Ukraine hatte vor Kriegsbeginn etwa 44
Millionen Einwohner dann sind doch eine
ganze Reihe von
Einwohnern unter die russische Kontrolle
geraten das galt natürlich schon für
2014 das muss ich jetzt dazu sagen und
wir haben seit Kriegsbeginn eine
Flugbewegung von 7 bis 8 Millionen
Menschen gesehen so dass man den
Eindruck hat die Ukraine
haben längst nicht mehr die
Bevölkerungszahl die sich vorher mal
hatten möglicherweise liegt sie im
moment de factor unter 30 Millionen
dazu kommt dass man eine große
mobilisierungswelle in der Ukraine ja
bereits hatte wir müssen davon ausgehen
dass bis zu einer Million Frauen und
Männern nun bewaffnete Dienste leisten
in den verschiedensten Einrichtungen
nicht alle bei der Armee viele bei der
territoreifachung oder Hilfsdiensten
aller Art und die Frage ist wie weit
kann man das noch ausschöpfen in
Russland ist normal die Personalzahl
sehr viel höher allerdings gibt es einen
großen Unterschied in der Ukraine
scheint man ist der Großteil der
Bevölkerung der Meinung dass man sich
verteidigen muss und sie sind bereit bis
jetzt zumindest hohe Opfer zu bringen
das ist der ganz erstaunlich und auch
bewunderungswürdig in Russland sieht das
natürlich etwas anders aus man hat sehr
viel mehr Menschen zur Verfügung die man
mobilisieren könnte man wird das
versuchen aber je mehr der Krieg die
Familien in Russland erreicht umso
unruhiger könnte dass er innenpolitisch
auch für Putin werden nur hatten wir
schon zu Beginn diskriminiert gesagt
dass damit Risiken für Putin verbunden
sind und das hat sich bisher nicht
bewahrheitet ich glaube eher die Risiken
und dieses Gefühl für Verluste muss erst
die russischen Eliten erreichen bevor
sich hier politisch etwas ändert also
wie gesagt
die Durchhaltefähigkeit Russland der
Zahl nach ist höher der Moral nach es
ist bei der Ukraine
Stichwort Risiken ein Kommentar von
daher schwarz bei Youtube der sich fragt
wieso droht die USA nicht einfach mit
heimat-raketen mit 200 Kilometern
Reichweite wenn die Russen nicht mit den
Drohnen und Raketen Terror auf die
zivile Infrastruktur aufhören also hier
eine Frage nach einer Eskalationsstufe
ja nun wir haben ja ganz deutlich gehört
von westlichen politischen Führern dazu
zähle ich insbesondere Präsident beiden
aber natürlich auch unseren
Bundeskanzler Scholz oder Präsident
macron von Frankreich dass man eine
Eskalation um jeden nicht um jeden Preis
aber dass man die Eskalation vermeiden
wird es gibt also die Festlegung dass
die NATO-Staaten nicht Teile nicht an
Krieg selbst teilnehmen werden das ist
also ein einheitliche Feststellung und
zweitens hatten bei der Lieferung der
Raketen auch deutlich gemacht
Raketen dass man zunächst mal nur die
kürzere Reichweite nimmt nämlich die
etwa mit 70 bis 80 km und nicht die
Langstrecken Rakete die bis zu 380 km
geht und zum zweiten hat er sich selbst
dafür versprechen lassen dass man auch
die kürzere Reichweite nicht dafür
einsetzt über russische Grenzen
hinwegzuschießen wir können es
sicherlich eine Grauzone hier aber das
Gefühl dafür dass man eine Eskalation
vermeiden will ist auch in den in der
amerikanischen Führung stark entwickelt
selbstverständlich in der deutschen und
deswegen glaube ich im Moment nicht dass
man das tun wird wir dürfen nicht
vergessen wir haben es mit einer mit der
Möglichkeit mehrerer Eskalationsstufen
zu tun das eine ist eine horizontale
Erweiterung das andere ist aber auch
eine vertikale Erweiterung dieses
kriegsszenarios die man könnte sehr
gering ausfallen ich meine hier dass wir
es zu tun haben mit der größten der
zweitgrößten nuklear macht dieser Erde
mit Russland und ein eine nuklear macht
mag sich auch teresaal mal hier und da
zurückziehen aber es wird sie wird nicht
kapitulieren und wer dann noch weiter
geht und da auf den Zerfall Russlands
spekuliert der wird ein Szenario damit
an die Wand nein dass keiner im Westen
will eine nuklear macht die politisch
zerfällt ist so ziemlich das Übelste
Szenario das ist für die Stabilität
weltweit geben kann und das sind alles
gute Gründe um dreimal nach zu DENKEN
bevor man jetzt mit Langstreckenwaffen
die Ukraine befähigt die russischen
Streitkräfte völlig zu ruinieren wenn
sie dazu wenn in der Lage wären ich
glaube ein paar Raketen tun das auch
nicht aber man ist hier vorsichtig und
das wird wieder Grund sein warum breiten
eben auch diese Zurückhaltung wart und
das gilt natürlich auch für Deutschland
Frankreich und andere westeuropäische
Staaten
es gibt Experten die der Meinung sind
dass wenn es für beide Seiten keinen
Raumgewinn mehr gibt das dann so etwas
wie ein Waffenstillstand eintreten
könnte wie stehen Sie dazu
ja also ich habe ja vorhin gesagt wenn
der Leidensdruck auf beiden Seiten so
steigt oder auf einer hat dass man sagt
es wir können das nicht mehr
verantworten also hier kommen ja
moralisch ethische Bedingungen ins Spiel
oder Kriterien gespielt wir können es
nicht mehr verantworten dem Erfolg
weitere Opfer aufzubürden wir müssen
irgendwo ein Schlussstrich ziehen und
wenn wir auch militärisch nicht mehr
weiterkommen dann ist das natürlich
wahrscheinlich genau das Signal was man
dann leider ist es so vom Schlachtfeld
braucht es geht nicht mehr voran es ist
jetzt vernünftiger jetzt einen
Waffenstillstand zu machen bevor man in
einem verlustreichen aber sehr
intensiven Stellungskrieg nur noch Opfer
fährt so ein Pferd sozusagen das kann
der Fall sein das muss nicht so sein
aber das kann der Fall sein und man darf
vielleicht sogar davon ausgehen dass es
auch in nach den nächsten großen
offensiven die sicherlich folgen werden
jetzt Ende Winter oder früher das ist
dann zu einer sol Situation kommen kann
aber genau Vorauswahl lässt sich so
etwas nicht denn überall sind Menschen
am Werk und Entscheidungsträger und es
entstehen in politische Dynamiken die
man schwer absehen kann im Moment die
betriebliche Botschaft zu Beginn des
Jahres ist dass alle Seiten gewillt sind
diesen Krieg vorzusetzen dass sie die
Ressourcen dafür haben dass Russland die
allerdings aus nationalen Bedarf der
Bereich erstellen kann während die
Ukraine auf den Westen angewiesen ist um
nach und nach immer mehr Munition und
Ersatzteile zu liefern und sich damit
die politische Verantwortung immer mehr
auf den Westen auch verlagert und wir
unter diesen Bedingungen sehen müssen
wie man den Krieg erstmal begrenzen kann
wie man Bedingungen erreichen kann die
auch einigermaßen akzeptabel sind ich
befürchte dass es ohne schmerzliche
Einbußen dann aber auf keiner Seite
gehen kann denn alle müssen dann von
Maximalposition runterkommen eine Frage
zu diesen Einbußen ob das also die
Zukunft beeinflussen könnte stellt sich
der User Hayabusa Film bei YouTube fragt
sich kann man Russland durch die hohen
Verluste an den Verhandlungstisch
zwingen
ich denke wenn nur unter der Bedingung
dass damit innenpolitische Unruhen
verbunden sind wenn also der Druck aus
der aus dem Volk heraus die politischen
Eliten in Russland erreicht dann mag es
so sein aber man darf auch nicht die
andere Seite vergessen wir haben vorhin
davon gesprochen dass wir auf beiden
Seiten wenn wir mal zusammenrechnet es
mit bisher 200.000 Verlusten zu tun
haben davon etwa 25 bis 30%. dazu was
wir noch nicht gesagt haben ist wir
kommen noch mal etwa 40.000
zivile Verluste auch das kann man etwas
so rechnen dass man etwa 10.000 Tote hat
die UNO geht noch von etwas niedrigeren
Zahlen aus aber ich glaube die sind noch
nicht ganz erfasst also
der Leidensdruck wird sich dann erhöhen
das ist schon richtig
keiner kann im Moment vorauszusagen wann
der Kessel so voll ist dass er platzt
und dass man dann sagt jetzt reicht wir
brauchen einen Waffenstillstand wir
müssen allerdings davon ausgehen dass
die Ukraine ihre Souveränität verteidigt
das heißt dass dort der Kampfwille und
die Moral vermutlich länger andauern
wird und härter ist als bei den
russischen Soldaten die eigentlich ja
sich immer die Frage stellen müssen auf
welchem Gebiet stehe ich hier was tue
ich hier warum bringe ich meine Brüder
um das ist ja eine brüdernation das gilt
ja nach wie vor und ist das alles
sinnvoll was ich dafür und das scheint
sich ja doch in Russland ganz anders
abzuspielen in der russischen Armee von
Elite Tropfen mal abgesehen
das heißt ja häufig auch die meisten
Kriege enden nicht durch Verhandlungen
also warum sollte das hier vielleicht
auch anders sein
naja die Kriege Enden entweder durch den
völligen Sieg der ein oder der anderen
Seite oder durch ein Erschöpfungszustand
der dann in einem
dauerhaften nicht Krieg ohne Verhandlung
übergeht was natürlich ein eingefrorener
Konflikt ist aber im Regelfall Enden
Kriege ja wenn wir mal von den beiden
großen Weltkriegen abzieht oder von den
früheren kolonial kriegen die natürlich
immer zugunsten
in der Regelfall werden Kriege auch
durch Verhandlung beendet das ist
historisch alles da gewesen und das ist
auch hier denkbar
dann hätte ich noch zum Schluss eine
Frage aus der Community von wolkeninsel
bei Youtube er oder sie fragt kann das
ein Krieg werden der noch fünf bis zehn
Jahre gehen wird rechnet irgendjemand
mit einem baldigen Ende
also ich glaube nicht dass man in der
Lage ist ein Krieg von 5 bis 10 Jahren
in der Intensität durchzuhalten die
jetzt zu beobachten ist dann wird es
eher ein eingefrorener Konflikt werden
das heißt das mittelszenario dass ich
gerade erwähnt habe der dadurch endet
dass man erschöpft ist und dass man eine
gewisse
Vorläufe kontaktlinien für eine Weile
hält aber selbst das müsste organisiert
werden es muss ja dann immer versucht
werden eine weitere Eskalation zu
verhindern und ich vermute das selbst so
einen vorübergehender Status einer
gewissen Regelung bedarf und das haben
wir ja auch schon gesehen zum Beispiel
den Minsker Abkommen wie das
funktionieren kann wenn es auch am Ende
nicht befriedigend war aber das
mittleres Szenario halt ich auch für ein
denkbares ich hoffe natürlich auch ein
Szenario dass ein Waffenstillstand
hervorbringt unter verhandelten und
vernünftigen Bedingungen
sagt general Oberst ad Wolfgang Richter
vielen Dank dass Sie bei uns zu Gast
waren heute
vielen Dank Frau jung Ihnen einen
schönen Abend Dankeschön und natürlich
auch für euch einen schönen Abend danke
dass ihr dabei wart für eure Fragen für
eure Kommentare ich habe versucht zu
viele wie möglich davon mitnehmen zu
können das Thema natürlich wird bei uns
auch immer wieder zunächst mal natürlich
hier wiederkehren und wir bleiben für
euch dran gehen dann wieder live bis
dahin erstmal schönen Abend und danke